try that right now my determine are each
other's work in let's do this so it's
funny so this is very much more of a
Japanese beta you have to push a gift
apush be to go forward normally you know
you push a american games but in
Japanese games you tend to have to push
the ship was used to annoy me when I
through menus yeah like that Metal Gear
Solid demos and whatnot we're all about
that I guess everybody should have
learned how to play the game so so peter
is the one who took the who took the
demo for this but he's feeling a little
bit sick yeah a little under the weather
he go probably at the pact box let's be
honest so we banished him from the
office the thing that the cook in this
game is being able to dash through
enemies so you hit a guy not like you
see how he turned kind of blue can dash
through them loops and you kind of
absorb their power so blue is I think
health and it lets you get the room a
little bit faster that is the first
level of the game this is the oaken
green center yes so the beta is just
this one stage or is there any way that
capcom's not going to try to take some
legal action against not not at this
point this this dude looks hella like
megaman Sam he's definitely Megaman
looking but mega man doesn't dance
through enemy so you just saw I picked
up that red power up I had a green one
it's running out use your fire powers it
makes it a little bit stronger hits
enemies quite a bit harder you know the
chain those jumps one yep so you can
which it'll be some platforming coming
up where you'll definitely have to do
that and you have to be careful with
these blocks because they will all on
you if you shoot through them take that
blocks and it's early so there is a
there's kind of a bottom slide like that
letting on his face oh my god that shin
chafing at Peter was on me before we've
set the graphics to like relatively near
the low end of the scale because
apparently the beta is it's pretty
choppy well well optimized yeah he was
seems capturing footage earlier and
you're like a beta thing yeah I look
pretty bad look for did you got like a
dash situation or something a dash
situation I don't know that's what
doesn't that doesn't that green thing
look like its sale yeah so the green MIT
lets you move a little bit faster yeah
that's what I'm talking about man so I
can move a little bit faster now
running out of the red those explosions
will hurt you as well you move up he
feels like you live a little bit slow
look at that guy it's another version
you are you sure who that helicopter guy
yeah gay times a day it did you play
much to play much Megaman back in thick
or even the new ones even uh-oh Becca
that ain't no I was actually never a
really big Megaman person not especially
not as much as Peter and yes what about
you Chris I didn't have a megaman type
system back in the day the best people
to be sawing this video so I played a
little bit you know at friends houses
and stuff but I did not have access to
it in my on my home turf how long how
long is this demo is the first time it's
been playable this is the first time
that everyone's putting all the plates
were probably about 10 15 minutes to get
through it one other interesting thing
that you didn't necessarily have an in
the mega man games is that as you
collect these items you see when I pause
I have a stock of items I've held starts
12 you can use that to refill your
health what attacks hacks hacks or
plates you still have that go back go
back to using like a health photo I used
it one okay now all right we're just
works do they have a little bit a little
bit faster this time I just no need to
show that it's amazing what was in that
tips menu oh don't next in big game
without saving find a long was it what
was in there I you know telling you how
to play out like how the dash part works
I didn't read through that so I actually
don't know I played it a little like
Peter was like hey I'm feeling sick I
can't make it true yeah can you play the
game for me I said oh okay and people
can't get access to this to this stage
right if they were like born into the
beta now you if they put into beta they
can do it right they can play right now
but I guess they can't now because
Kickstarter's not like IndieGoGo work
they have closed entrance today you're
not going to be able to keep doing this
so like it's a bit of a close thing now
but if you were at pax and you happen to
drop by the their booth mmm you would
have got another chance to get this as
well do you know when because this is
this beta is accessible via Steam and so
do you know if this is coming out
in the neck in the near future or
because I'm wondering if they'd be
tempted to go towards the early access
route as well on this one I don't think
they've given us a date on the full game
yet it's a weird thing where some
developers once they kind of as long as
they get their your Kickstarter people
early they kind of don't mind opening it
up and becoming more like acceptable to
do that now like you and a later by in
once at least the Kickstarter people
have been like serviced first as it was
you mean one way to put it you mean me
yes as long as you've satisfied you did
that last time where you stood next to
the barrel and shot at how you were I
don't learn from my mistakes okay fair
enough April 2015 is the release days
apparently they apparently it's still
coming out on all of these ridiculous
consoles 3ds Linux Mac ps3 ps4 Vita
windows 360 Xbox one and they also
apparently releasing a check on the
Nintendo eShop for the nintendo store
for for wii u and i'm not sure if
they're gonna be end up staggering those
I would you know II think so sometime
pick a team making it either all right
go to title yeah yeah see that again
almost there to go almost did it no its
you know what your full version they're
probably javi are you sure text box pop
up though if mr. and funa is watching
right now please sir please protect us
from ourselves if not for for Justin
than for the rest of us watching do you
see my D number five talking me in the
background there is taunting me telling
me how much I suck wait who what mighty
number fuss see your mighty number nine
in this game uh-huh there are some IDs
yeah if I don't the other I am Number
One or for whatever I was see I man I am
yeah no I didn't see it but it's ringing
a bell you listen that robot was just
peacefully going about its crate
carrying business you busted it's great
of course it's gonna get mad hmm one of
you wonder he see that was a creative
death just choose to live i'm just doing
jokes oh man look at the it's the z axis
axis is that another someone helping you
on the back they like froze those dudes
Jason Jason she's a good guy Hawks
you know what's happening ever since
everyone started calling you J hey now
I'm calling Jason for absolutely no
reason Jason hey too many there too too
many J names in the off my wall you've
called him like three different things
on this show so being a date dungus
ain't my gig at this level all right I'm
good we're gonna let you try and
complete the big this bad boy if you
complete it before yes I ran through it
once right a little bit before the show
all right so you'll notice that if you
don't absorb the guys they do they do
disappear oh no how you feel about this
because I'll be honest this looks like
super generic ah i'm not i'm not totally
into it i feel like these games are best
served when they are difficult so
perhaps because this is like the early
level I'm not really getting the best of
that but I did get to play through this
already so I I had a lot more trouble
the first time that I tried this oh no
and the controls are a little
interesting it's you get used to it but
interesting huh that doesn't sound
possible just thing sounds like a really
nice way of saying oh the spikes are all
one hit deaths okay I could start not
all shouldn't go all the way back to the
start yeah I don't have to go that far
and I one we're talking with peace and
out of this kid in Ganges and we're
mentioning to people gang beasts a
player is the most difficult thing to
set up ever we had it working earlier at
currently it looks like we only have
about five lights on these controller so
we might just do a four-player game but
in any case we'll get into that in a
minute oh Justin I believe in you except
i'm indy shuttle I i I'd be honest or
not actually believing in him that much
you know you can do it you do it dungus
nice okay it's getting a little more
difficult there and then we're gonna
come up against the boss the boss is a
very standard megaman kind of enemy is
it okay where you at I'll go get the
secret have to say great
oh yeah belly slide oh I got up what
does that thing did say an extra length
oh you say dropped you right on the bugs
you an extra life and then drops you
want to go mine right that's it see you
on suckers later then you think about
time for this number five taunting me
again number Five's a jerk cuz are you
fighting number five have you I will
they gone rogue oh this is another two
guys number 52 boss number five is gonna
be the boss of this stage oh no you end
up fighting all of them oh whoa could
say nice dashing all that dudes bone oh
he doesn't sound um phone hahaha you're
in a tight spot come on you can do it
give any he'll start like bloody whether
or not and maybe he'll give me something
yeah eat it maybe he'll take them from
you forklift garbage can no Kiki home
fire I might not make it i did not have
health elastic Justin I believe I
believe in you Jason we believe in both
Justin and Jason so whoever you're
feeling like today I'm dungus I don't
believe in dungus dungus is a myth oh
alright got one more chance we ready
very even come up with that name the
name of her child mighty number nine
coming to every console known to mankind
April 2015 you got domed by Miss Justin
hey Walt thank you very much going on
sorry I'll eat it
you